what's going on guys
Expendables those old fogies will not
stop cranking out movies they're teaming
up now but there was a time when they
fought to see who ruled the 80s action
box office we're gonna decide right here
right now what is the greatest 80s
action film of all time and we have a
super cool panel to help us figure that
out first he is one of the schmoes of
schmoes know Kristian harloff what's
going on I can't wait to tempte scout
how many Arnold impressions will be done
in this episode he's also a Schmo he's
the cute one the boyband SMO it's Mark
Ellis and he's single girls and we're
very lucky to have this guy from red
letter media Jay Baumann hello I'm from
Milwaukee it does exist so guys there
were a lot of movies to choose from to
put together our 16 movie bracket the
80s was a long decade it was there are
at least 10 years in the 80s and there
are a lot of movies to choose from so we
have some ground rules the movies we
picked have to include either a
terrorist a drug lord buddy cops or
Schwarzenegger or Stallone as I was
saying we have 16 films and we wanted to
see them as objectively as possible so
we used the IMDB rankings totally
objective all right Chris Jennifer we'll
start with you first matchup the number
one movie die hard against the number 16
seed Sylvester Stallone's Cobra you know
go up against Jordan if you're not even
in the pros die hard Jay I will die hard
is not just a great 80s action movie but
just a great movie in general Cobra is
not as good of a movie but it does have
the best death of the villain of any of
the movie offices yeah grabs the guy and
pails him on a giant hook and then he
goes through a furnace that's a brutal
movie and it goes down in brutal defeat
diehard moving on to the next round next
in the bracket set up our number 9 seed
48 hours against our number 8 seed
escape from New York now Jay I see
you're wearing an escape from New York
t-shirt
I got to hear from you first on this one
uh escape from New York is one of my
favorite movies period but it's not a
good action movie it's very clunky and
awkward and slow so who do you like 48
hours or escape from New York which you
are talking I'm gonna go this gay
frontier because I love it even though I
don't think it works as an action movie
Ellis
heylook March Madness is about chemistry
and I love Nick Nolte an Eddie Murphy
they're very funny together but on
screen they're at each other's throats
the whole movie I think Snake Plissken
takes this one well wish my bullet
counted for three because I'm taking 48
hours and that means nothing escapes the
first round next we have a number four
seat against number 13 seed number four
lethal weapon against number 13
Rambo First Blood Part two okay know
what though I just took the one for the
individual beast the team I can't do it
again as much as I love John ranima
Riggs and Murtaugh they had better
sequels than Rambo did too so I got to
go with lethal weapon caster w14 lethal
weapon harloff rambo blows up a guy with
an arrow and exploding arrows the first
time anyone saw something like that it's
like that is better use anything in
lethal weapon but it's not better than
Riggs and Murtaugh i lethal weapon takes
it I'm sorry John
Oh lethal weapon in a romp the next one
in this bracket number 12 seed Roadhouse
against number 5 Robocop Robocop from
Oakland icon Ellis you know sometimes 12
beats of 5 every year in March Madness
but it ain't happening this time
Roadhouse loses to Murphy yeah that for
a dollar okay here's a high seat against
a low seed there are number two seed the
Terminator against number 15 Delta Force
I like Terminator better than Terminator
2 so I would always take terminus one my
favorite okay Jay I also like the first
Terminator more than the second one and
I've never seen Delta Force alright oh
this is another barn burner our number
10 seed Schwarzenegger commando against
number 7 Big Trouble in Little China uh
Jay got to start with you again on this
one again I love John Carpenter I love
big trouble little China but as far as
80s action movies go I gotta go with
commando wow this is like the perfect
80s action movie yeah well guess much as
I love Kurt Russell in the 80s I can't
take him over on which Schwarzenegger
especially when he's looking for Alyssa
Milano that's something
not a weak Karloff Big Trouble in Little
China is a very fun entertaining
adventure film and it's Kurt Russell at
his height again rocking a fantastic
mullet you're hung up on these malas you
have to have a great mole to eat it you
have to have a great one but even though
he has now a mullet Arnold
Schwarzenegger in commando is like any
young ones just throwing jokes Alec do
me a favor don't disturb my friend he's
dead tired
no contest great oh boy here's another
high seed low seed matchup back to
Schwarzenegger with predator coming in
at number 3 and number 14 Steven Seagal
above the law Ellis I think predator
might be the most dangerous team in this
entire tournament I think seating it at
3 is doing is doing disservice everybody
else including this team has to play at
predator wins easily Jay predator by far
so predator moves on there and our last
matchup of the first round
Schwarzenegger again in the running man
against Eddie Murphy Beverly Hills Cop
oh that's Jay I think i'ma have to go to
the running man cuz I always think of
Beverly Hills Cop is more of a comedy
than an action movie he's not falling
for a banana in his tailpipe he's
picking running man Ellis when I was a
kid I want to be Eddie Murphy a lot more
than I wanted to be our own
Schwarzenegger I got a go at Beverly
Hills Cop Running Man was the first
Hunger Games and battle royal and it's a
Stephen King short story it has the most
effort to it behind it it's a really fun
movie as richard dawson running man wins
Wow guys so we end the first round with
the 11 seed taken down the six seed
let's go to round 2 we have our number
one seed diehard against our number 8
seed escape from New York
Ellis diehard I think Bruce Willis is
gonna be the Danny Manning of this
tournament was just gonna run through
everybody and he's gonna do it through
Kurt Russell not what are we that sounds
weird Jake I loved it using all these
basketball bracket terms cuz I don't
know what the hell were talking about
but a die-hard is a better action movie
Lydon Escape from New York there you go
I wanted to get rid of him the first
friend I can get rid of him in the
second round see later snake I'm a big
fan but it's all about John McLean
diehard moving on in a romp ok lose
another good one we got the number four
seed lethal weapon against the number
five seed Robocop how I'm gonna base
this is what it's spawned its spawn two
three and Robocop flying so because of
that the franchise in whole I'm going
Riggs and Murtaugh that was really
toughest hours if we're talking about
basketball you can't judge Michael
Jordan based on what his kids have done
I'm gonna go with Robocop is going to
defeat Lethal Weapon because we the
weapon was very funny but Robocop had a
dark sense of humor with it along with
all that great action Robocop takes it
in the optician bows are divided and Jay
guess what your vote decides this
nobody gets doused in toxic waste and
lethal weapons so I have to get with
ruffle oh sorry lethal weapon is getting
too old for this get a crazy Oh the rest
of this thing is all Schwarzenegger
number two Terminator against number ten
commando Jay Oh Terminator is a better
movie it's got more ideas going on it's
got better action it's not as funny of
course but it's a better movie overall
Ellis it doesn't matter what I say guys
I know what Chris is gonna answer and I
don't want to get tons of internet hate
so I'll say Terminator Christian uh yeah
you don't know what I'm gonna say
because I don't know what I'm gonna say
at this point because commando for me is
a movie like like Jay said you can laugh
your balls off watching a movie so
stupid and great little some steam
Bennett keep your balls and get
Terminator Terminator alright commando
is gonna go let off some steam little
some steam Bennett got to do it it's
gone okay our last match for the second
round number three predator against
number 11 running man
ooh boy Ellis this was a game show then
I think running man would be voted off
the island real quick predator for the
win and I don't see it stopping anytime
soon boys harloff predators in movie I
don't care if it's an 80s movie this is
a movie that holds up today it is just a
fantastic movie for Team four
performances everything about it yeah
whatever the supporting cast and
predator oh it's the bus I mean even the
miner hair like Jesse Ventura is in it
for two seconds but he's still memorable
all the camera Carl Weathers is in it
yeah poor weathers is in predator guys
what's the matter
the CIA got to pushing too many pencils
huh
uh J thoughts or any man is miner
Schwarzenegger a predator it starts out
as a Rambo and it turns into alien by
the end and it's great wow that's a
great summation of it predator moving on
big moment you guys we are down to the
final four die-hard vs Robocop J
thoughts
I love Robocop Oh
of the ideas in it I think it's a really
clever satire but as far as straight
ahead 80s action goes I have to go with
diehard one for die-hard Dyer it's gonna
be moving on but I look as far as
Robocop is it is an absolutely
tremendous story as well because what
they did they took chances with that
film but die hard what you did with John
McClane it just resonated with audiences
so fire
Ellis thoughts look Alex Murphy had a
robot suit John McClane didn't even have
shoes yeah I heard he's moving on to the
final die hard
moving on to the finals and once again
we come to Schwarzenegger on
Schwarzenegger crime Terminator vs. the
predator Wow oh that is new hardest
fight so far house tell us we're gonna
start off with you buddy this has been
the subject of many a bar debate late
night with Mark Ellis Terminator
franchise vs. predator but I think that
if you're going with the first predator
versus the first Terminator it's not a
contest predator is moving on oh boy
okay that is one for the predator
Christian again I'm doing the same thing
I did before is as far a single movie
and then franchise because there's only
been one good predator movie yeah I
gotta say we're not talking franchises
French oh no I know but I didn't I
didn't I didn't hey I just want to take
that what a quality movie the movie
itself
oh man predator versus Terminator
predator with the with the team aspect
and the one-liners and the predator
predator wins Jay I think Terminator is
a is a really great science fiction
story mm-hmm but as far as like a
straight ahead action movie goes I think
predator is a better action movie yep
damn you hell this is what it's all
about you guys it comes down to two
movies that cut through all the rounds
without a single defeat Bruce Willis and
diehard Arnold Schwarzenegger
predator 2 great 80s action films let's
give them a both a round of applause
well done gentlemen
LS talked to me this is the hardest
decision I've ever had to make in my
life
no that's obvious a human but it is I
think this game goes into overtime and I
think that the reason why it wins is
because of that scene when John McClane
jumps off the roof as it's exploding
it's still one of the greatest moments
in
history and that's why diehard gets a w
in OT diehard one o Kristian harloff
you're an evil bastard you know I I'm
gonna not just hedging bets but I am
going to say predator here Wow
this was Swartz a [ __ ] in his prime
this is fortunate where you see him you
see him as that badass action star we
know he is if you're going to early
eighties predator just that much I'm
sorry John McClane you're one of my
favorites of all time but semester
Stallone says you're a dick so for that
this is a great moment and sports you
guys it all comes down deadlocked 1-1
diehard predator J I'm the wrong person
you're all we've got everybody involved
this is a John McClane Nakatomi
situation yeah got the villain Ellis
with I harder yeah personally I like
predator more but if we're talking 80s
action movies I think of you know
everyday action star all-american action
star fighting weird foreign people and
that's die hard die hard is the greatest
80s action film and yeah it's also one
of the great Christmas movies of all
time and it's also got one of the great
villains of all time what do you think
is the greatest 80s action movie of all
time what do you think of these guys
picks let us know in the comments
section below best answer we're gonna
send you a screen junkies t-shirt I got
to thank my esteemed panel Kristian
harloff Marc Ellis schmoes no subscribe
to schmoes no and check out J Bachman on
red letter media it is fantastic I'm Hal
Rudnick thanks for watching hit me up on
Twitter bye bye